now I was doing Rogen and somebody
posted a terrible picture me go it's
time to get those legs Liz don't I look
like this I'm doing this oh you see the
picture I posted well she'll younger
than me yeah yeah and somebody up there
yeah somehow I was near Curie the band
is back the other Brian are back down
there all those together man
uh-huh I don't know that guy is that guy
so old no you don't look old there well
I'm different I look strange
they look different that was such a fun
night do you remember that night I do me
daliyah bill burr it's the best that
gosh it's the best it is it's the best
we get to be comics how funny take a
break go back yeah I have a bunch I'm
just keep posted on view of me look at
this one I laughed certify fell down
laughing I fell down laughing right when
you saw me that I started laughing so
[ __ ] hard look at Tito Ortiz saying
read till I laughed so [ __ ] hard
Eddie Bravo like oh it was so funny
whoever came out I mean I don't laugh
man that made me last so hard man oh my
god
Eddie Bravo fight companion they should
make one Brendan Schaub big boy bike
club everybody yeah that's a great meme
for all of that everything's a loudmouth
of time
show me um where do I look you're right
I thought that picture that one oh that
one with me it's a good picture little
boy tiger was all up on you ah he's so
far someone said your grandfather seems
nice boy and his two dads so cute it's
so cute man I was telling he's got a
great person a little Hercules cartoon
when he's a baby
yeah that's both the snakes yeah yeah
I've actually never seen a four-year-old
that kind of like muscular development
it's crazy not to toot my own kids horn
which I'm sure every dad does who's
listening but Jeff texting last night
news hey man I wouldn't just say this
he's around kids his gyms not give us
you have the most athletic four year on
I've ever seen
yeah that's a fact you need to do
something with it you should Pullman
track you would destroy keys so fast now
he's gonna be you know who knows swim B
who knows this right buddy who knows
okay what time I have to get his legs
done it was exhausted thank you she's
been going hard in the paint he never
stops moving doesn't stop
he's so I get home it's on I so cute
today we ride our bikes in in the front
lawn just in circles for an hour
he wasn't she has the sparkling water he
says he was dead leave you here don't
let anybody touch it just don't don't
don't let it spill God doesn't dude but
also don't let anybody take it okay I'm
gonna go over there I'm gonna come back
I'm gonna drink something but don't let
it spilled the way he was there was a
conspiratorial of and they did a double
backflip I've never seen a child
I flipped me off yep and flips you off
yeah yeah your nose your nose is
beginning to change shape see this is
what happens when I was fighting
especially before I fought you know it
was very different
my nose is pointing yeah and now your
nose is doing what it happens to older
well first of all I knows you might have
the same nose and my nose is crooked
yeah and notice the gray my beard yeah
that's where that's what happens Bubba
but here's what's happened
you know hard like physically hard the
hardest life yeah you have yeah I mean
the amount of training and and it does
make you that does grow your hair it's
strange your body yeah yeah look at that
look at my nose is broken that one
broken that one broken that one mmm-hmm
no broken that you so much like Aaron
Hernandez
this is an older one that one yeah damn
look at that
that's your what 20 23 24 yeah 24 buddy
that's [ __ ] crazy dude crazy
alrighty yeah okay well that fun going
back going through our old pictures man
we have so many yeah that's pretty great
look at that well that's under
beautifulpeople.com I doubt we're on
that bro
you're not swiping I highly doubt you're
also in that put in put in Bryan Callen
Bryan Callen hot there you go my regular
oh my god go go back or go to the final
kid post there seasoned green remember
Sugar Shane Mosley yes I'm in there and
had raps on and that's how I did the
podcast yeah he did clutch with no shirt
and raps on it's very strictly give you
some good work look how good-looking you
were there I'm a cute kid those were the
days
I look like Ryan Bader five years ago
yeah Ryan better Boehner to stretch but
Wow yes service you look like his coach
his wrestling coach he used to wrestle
back in the day no my neck is thick
master chem shirt I like those master
Kim's shirts see - we should do
something we should do those again those
are great that that a specific one is
great with the purple that's [ __ ]
great yeah we had to a master Kim's one
again yeah I love that design I don't
know if you want to break the wood at
your fitting know what we'll do a new
one love that love that one there's hot
right there - that's I was gonna have
movie I was naked yeah I could hear
they're starting to go I was cute look
at how cute I was back now you're a
cutie man cutie patootie cutie Boop Joe
has a very short torso he can't fit Joe
goes like that I hope he didn't this
joke but he's like he goes I look like a
thumb with two thumbs one of the
funniest joke I've ever heard
like a thumb with two problems you just
say that stage yeah I'm never gonna grow
tall so I'm growing east to west
he says Joe Rona's karva diet was
disappointing irresponsible he got shred
City from that that's a plant-based news
now put put Bryan Callen young put
bright yellow dead
no that's the main picture is Matt crazy
yes you are Frazier I remember this
episode - was that what oh my god Bryan
you look so much better
I do look at me there what if that was
preached hair transplant the heads
that's crazy
okay look at be shot with this with this
with this tank that was on that show us
with you and wrap oh well that would we
have a couple of buttons man buns look
it Rogen right there that's a good
picture and there I was there I was
there I was filming that yeah you were
when was that years ago that was a mouth
four years ago five you three live that
long ago I think so I've been doing
mayor Youngsville
you are not dense ville you and I have
been Maddie or juice is you and I
started doing the first fire in kid
almost six years ago Ontario had been
right around then till five or six years
ago yeah that's what you're talking
about
what's next for me lids dude will last
okay I never think about here trans but
not there's so many better than yeah but
this all becomes a slippery slope that's
a great picture of Rogan back that was
when Rogan here go down I was boxing
they sure had it that's Rogan right
there that was when he was shredded in
my age and back when he was 20 he's
twenty nine twenty cent man yeah he was
[ __ ] fish and bass well know it's
worth a lot of money I thought he wasn't
before it's fine how your face changes
all you can do is yeah father time
because then you know what we're just
gonna drag your drawers down like yeah
we're gonna do a bunch of stuff oh my
god I look like Lee Harvey Oswald there
yeah it's so funny oh my god that's
hilarious
never put those together we definitely
look like him look into it that's
[ __ ] crazy we are at the guy Awards
how long ago was that dude say we looked
this up last time John 15 right yeah you
could never have a guy Awards these days
Mitrione was there too
I miss my that's right that's good
people there's my old girlfriend right
there is that weird she was gorgeous
what a great girl oh you look good dude
yeah I'm like hi I look like I look
great I'm so I just look like a scum you
look at your scumbag agent there yeah
she was such a great girl that girl
the young loved her I hear so not long
now maybe more tears wasn't zette zette
zette well what did she sent sullivan
she looks at she's an actress we take a
little Tinkerbell she was she was an
actress and outlaw a little wild cat
awesome just an outlaw yeah what do you
mean oh don't worry about if your buddy
was over no no no no none of that none
of that she's a mother now and
shut up okay she's a good person yeah
good girl smart smart no doubt very
intelligent yeah and very talented yeah
that's so cool
well boys yoga now oh wow damn what do
you mean by outlaw though I thought that
man was like their outlaw I think biker
gangs I know like I like a real gypsy
like a gypsy oh that one like I see Mike
a free spirit a free spirit like a foot
like a forest nip like willing the will
whatever you know whatever the move I
don't like the way you're talking and I
don't like your face right now kinda no
more like the way you're all like no she
seemed like I don't know if no no no no
no Lou no no
hey watch watch self because I'm I'm
feeling loose and I'll fight you
I'm always down for a good fight don't
you have your leg plant [ __ ] thing I
do I might head so I have to be a little
careful yeah so here's the thing the
first thing I do I take this thick palm
that's all [ __ ] up for mountain biking
and I would slap you on the side your
head oh because I don't know how to
[ __ ] counter catch and counter the
minute I do you don't block it yeah the
minute I get I block I I don't even know
what I'm doing I go Bob I hit with the
same hats fine you always slap you you
know you got eggplant condition right
bro I'm a man your man and I stand my
ground 100% I'll tell you something now
tell me what you mean by Wildcat
this eye has been twitching for about 40
that's another fall apart that's
missions right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]